let's talk about the three best remedies
for
psoriasis if you have psoriasis you
definitely need to watch this entire
video
i put a tremendous amount of research
into this topic to summarize it to make
it
extremely simple and to hopefully help
you
so there's some really simple things you
can do
that are non-toxic the greek word for
psoriasis comes from
sora means itchy and iastis means
action or condition so it's an itchy
condition
psoriasis is an autoimmune condition
where your body is
producing antibodies against itself so
the symptoms of psoriasis
are coming from your own immune system
and
certain parts of your skin are replaced
every three to five days
instead of every 28 to 30 days so we
have this accelerated reproduction
of skin cells and that's what creates
the redness
and the scaling and the little white
flakes
that are on the like the little plaque
so here's what's going on
there is a t cell dysfunction
the t cells are part of the immune
system that's called the acquired immune
system you're not born with it you
develop it over time
and there's a dysfunction going on an
imbalance
triggered usually by an altered
microbiome either in your gut
or a really really bad sore throat a
strep throat
or another infection and there's
several different types of t cells the
one that is involved
is the t helper cell th17 it's called
and this happens to be your own immune
cell that induces
inflammation and autoimmune diseases
and also it releases cytokines so it has
an additional
inflammatory signal on top of that
now there's other t cells called the t
regulatory cells that are involved in
preventing
autoimmune diseases in the first place
and those are usually suppressed
so we have a suppressed t regulatory
cell
and we have an increase in t helper
cells th17
now if you do some research on this
you're going to find some interesting
data
on the relationship between the t helper
cell th17
and vitamin d vitamin d happens to be
something that can suppress th17
and so this is very interesting because
vitamin d
is not really a vitamin it's a hormone
that acts like cortisol in the body
which happens to be one of the big
treatments for psoriasis
prednisone and anti-inflammatory so
vitamin d is a natural
prednisone without the side effects the
other interesting thing about this
is that psoriasis is worse in the winter
why
because the vitamin d is going to be
lower also there's higher
incidence of psoriasis the further you
live from the equator
and if you have psoriasis you're a
greater risk for depression
and one of the big root causes of
depression is a vitamin d
so we have vitamin d very very important
i would recommend 40 000 iu's
every single day you need to take enough
to penetrate
sometimes the damage that's in the colon
that's not allowing you to absorb the
vitamin d
there's usually an altered microbiome so
you have to take a little bit more
now cod liver oil not only does cod live
oil have vitamin d
and vitamin a which is also good for the
skin but it also has the omega-3 fatty
acids
dha and epa and one of the main symptoms
of an omega-3 fatty acid deficiency
is dry scaly red
skin also omega-3 is an
anti-inflammatory
the last remedy is bile salts
why because bile salts stimulate the
vitamin d receptor
bile salts allow vitamin d to work a lot
better in the body so if there's any
type of
resistance let's say you have some
genetic alteration in your receptor for
vitamin d
it's called a polymorphism this will
help potentially increase the absorption
also bile salts directly modulate or
control
the t helper cell 17 the th17
cell so bile salts are going to help to
regulate this dysfunction
as well as stimulate the t regulatory
cells that's the one that puts the fire
out
it helps to calm down the inflammation
so the type of bile salt i'm going to
recommend for this
would be tudka t-u-d-c-a i'm not
recommending a brand just get whatever
you can find that has good views
and take three to four per day it'll be
used to help you digest the dietary fat
what we want to do is to take an empty
stomach so it can actually focus on
helping regulate the immune system
and as far as the cod liver oil take
whatever is recommended on the bottle
that you buy
and the last two things i'm going to
recommend are fasting
very very very important for all
autoimmune conditions as well as
no gluten at all in the diet so go ahead
and apply this information
and comment down below i want to hear
your results
before you go if you have a question
about a product or
you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help